This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Back in May 2018, reporter Olivia Humphreys had her first baby. She remembers being in London, an allowed chaotic postnatal ward waiting to go home. And it was during this time that she was handed a small drawstring bag. Inside it, there was a little towel with a brand logo on it, a few tiny samples of baby shampoo and nappy cream, and a ton of coupons. For lots of products, I'd never. heard of, but apparently desperately needed now that I had a new baby.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。2018年5月，记者奥利维亚·汉弗莱斯生下了她的第一个孩子。她记得当时在伦敦，身处一个混乱的产后病房，等待着回家。就在那时，有人递给她一个小抽绳袋。袋子里有一条印着品牌标志的小毛巾、几份婴儿洗发水和尿布霜的小样，还有一大堆优惠券。很多产品我闻所未闻，但显然，既然有了新生儿，我就迫切需要它们。
It's always nice to get free stuff, but the bag didn't make me feel better. It just added to the sense that I was woefully under-prepared. It was in those first sleepless nights after she returned home with her son, that Olivia started to really consider her bag of coupons. Her mind drifted to a better alternative. And she wondered if there was anywhere in the world where new parents were sent home with something more substantial. And that's when I found out what new parents in Finland receive.
能拿到免费的东西总是件好事，但这个袋子并没有让我感觉好受些。它反而加深了我那种极其缺乏准备的感觉。在带着儿子回家后的那些不眠之夜里，奥利维亚开始真正审视她那袋优惠券。她的思绪飘向了一个更好的选择。她想知道世界上是否有什么地方，会让新手父母带着更实在的东西回家。就在那时，我发现了芬兰的新手父母会收到什么。
A very exciting day for us. Our Finnish Baby Box has arrived. Our package is here. We get two because we have twins. In Finland, new parents also get a package of freebies. But instead of a few sample-sized products and some advertising flyers, they get something else. The Finnish maternity package, or the baby box. So let's see what is in here.
对我们来说是非常激动人心的一天。我们的芬兰婴儿盒到了。我们的包裹到了。因为我们生的是双胞胎，所以我们收到了两个。在芬兰，新手父母也会收到一个免费礼包。但他们得到的不是几份试用装产品和一些广告传单，而是别的东西。芬兰的产妇礼包，也就是婴儿盒。让我们来看看里面有什么。
T'da. Good Lord, there's so much stuff in here. This is a blanket. Wow. This is beautiful. Oh my God, it's got bears on it. So soft. Very soft.
当当。天哪，这里面的东西真多。这是一条毯子。哇。这太漂亮了。天哪，上面还有小熊。好软。非常柔软。
Oh my gosh. Very, very cute. And look, a little toothbrush. They don't have any teeth. Why is this for? Later. For later. A Finnish Baby Box is a little bit of.
天哪。非常非常可爱。看，还有一把小牙刷。他们还没长牙呢。这是干什么用的？以后用。以后用。芬兰婴儿盒有点像……
is essentially a large cardboard box full of items for a newborn and its parents. Picture books, nipple cream, warm booties for the freezing finish winters. Basically a starter kit of everything you'll need for the first six months of a baby's life. Virtually every new parent in Finland is eligible to receive one. My first thought when I heard this was, of course, it's exactly what you'd expect of Finland, the happiest country on earth, with its widely revered education system and comprehensive welfare states. The Simpsons even has a whole episode making fun of just how freaking happy the Finns are.
本质上是一个装满了新生儿及其父母所需物品的大纸箱。绘本、乳头霜、适合芬兰严寒冬天的保暖靴。基本上就是你照顾宝宝前六个月所需一切的入门套件。芬兰几乎每一位新手父母都有资格领取一个。当我听到这个消息时，我的第一反应当然是：这正是你对芬兰的期待——世界上最幸福的国家，拥有广受推崇的教育体系和全面的福利国家制度。《辛普森一家》甚至有一整集都在调侃芬兰人到底有多幸福。
Oh, geez, I can't afford this. No, it's all free. Free? Who are you people? Well, in Finland, we're not only experts on nuclear power. But for six years in a row, we've been the happiest people in the world. Makes sense. She lives so close to Santa Claus. But there's more to the baby box than a nice perk for the first. the happiest parents in the world. In its almost 90 years of existence, the Finnish baby box has been
噢，天哪，我可买不起这个。不，这全是免费的。免费？你们是什么人？嗯，在芬兰，我们不仅是核能方面的专家，而且连续六年被评为世界上最幸福的人。说得通。她住得离圣诞老人那么近。但婴儿盒不仅仅是给世界上最幸福的父母的一项福利。在近90年的历史中，芬兰婴儿盒一直……
a basic survival tool, a national symbol, and a right of passage. So how did a simple cardboard box become so filled with meaning? To find out, we're going to take a peek inside the cutest little social engineering tool in the world. So the story of the baby box begins in Finland in the late 1930s. Finland wasn't in such great shape. That's design historian Michelle Miller Fisher. She told me that when the first baby box came out, Finland was almost unrecognizable. The birth rate was declining.
是一个基本的生存工具、一个国家象征，也是一种成人礼。那么，一个简单的纸箱是如何被赋予如此多意义的呢？为了找出答案，我们将一窥这个世界上最可爱的社会工程工具。婴儿盒的故事始于20世纪30年代末的芬兰。当时的芬兰状况并不好。这是设计历史学家米歇尔·米勒·费舍尔说的。她告诉我，当第一个婴儿盒问世时，芬兰几乎让人认不出来。出生率在下降。
Many babies that were born were in ill health and there was quite a high rate of infant mortality. In the early decades of the 20th century, most Finns were extremely poor. Finland had recently emerged from a brutal civil war and revolutions in neighbouring Russia meant it had also lost its biggest trading partner. Since most of the grain in Finland came from Russia,
许多新生儿健康状况不佳，婴儿死亡率相当高。在20世纪初的几十年里，大多数芬兰人极其贫穷。芬兰刚从一场残酷的内战中走出来，邻国俄罗斯的革命也意味着它失去了最大的贸易伙伴。由于芬兰的大部分谷物来自俄罗斯，
that loss meant that many people were left starving. Finns were living in crowded, unsanitary conditions, and dying from outbreaks of tuberculosis, smallpox, and measles. Child mortality in Finland was also higher than in the rest of Europe. Almost 20% of children didn't make it to their fifth birthday. And so the Finnish Social Welfare Committee decided, that maybe they could design something that would help in part to change this. And that policy intervention looked like, in the end,
这种损失意味着许多人陷入饥饿。芬兰人生活在拥挤、不卫生的环境中，死于肺结核、天花和麻疹的爆发。芬兰的儿童死亡率也高于欧洲其他地区。几乎20%的儿童活不到五岁。因此，芬兰社会福利委员会决定，也许他们可以设计一些东西，在一定程度上帮助改变这种状况。最终，这项政策干预看起来就像……
a set of designed objects within a box. The idea of distributing critical items to new mothers wasn't an entirely original one. Since the 1920s, a Finnish charity had been lending out baskets of baby essentials to the poorest families in Finland. The baskets contained clean baby clothes, hand-sown by volunteers, from donated bits of fabric. At the time, it was pretty common for mothers
一套装在盒子里的设计物品。向新妈妈分发关键物品的想法并非完全原创。自20世纪20年代以来，一家芬兰慈善机构一直在向芬兰最贫困的家庭出借装有婴儿必需品的篮子。篮子里装着志愿者用捐赠的碎布缝制的干净婴儿衣服。当时，母亲们……
to swaddle their newborns in old rags, and this gave them an alternative. Once the baby grew out of the clothes, the basket was passed on to the next family who needed it. The government used the baskets as a blueprint for something more ambitious. They kept the clean clothes and added basic hygiene items, like soap and towels,
用旧破布包裹新生儿是很常见的，而这为她们提供了一种替代方案。一旦婴儿长大了穿不下这些衣服，篮子就会传给下一个需要的家庭。政府将这些篮子作为蓝图，用于更宏大的计划。他们保留了干净的衣服，并增加了基本的卫生用品，如肥皂和毛巾，
to help slow the spread of disease. And instead of loaning it out, They decided to make the box a gift that families could keep. In 1938, they started giving these new packages out to struggling families, not in a basket, but in a cardboard box, a box that doubled as a crib. It has been from the day one that you could put your baby to sleep in the box. That's a Nina Kwoka. She works for Keller, the Finnish Social Security Agency.
以帮助减缓疾病的传播。他们决定不再出借，而是将盒子作为一份家庭可以保留的礼物。1938年，他们开始向困难家庭发放这些新礼包，不是用篮子，而是用纸箱，一个可以兼作婴儿床的盒子。从第一天起，你就可以让宝宝睡在盒子里。这是安妮娜·克沃卡。她在凯拉（芬兰社会保险局）工作。
Actually, in the early days, the families were poor, and their houses were small. There wasn't necessarily a safe and clean place to put the baby to sleep. So that's why it was quite important. When World War II broke out just one year later, Finland didn't have fabric to spare for the baby boxes. So the designers had to get creative.
实际上，在早期，家庭很贫穷，房子也很小。不一定有一个安全、干净的地方让宝宝睡觉。所以这就是它相当重要的原因。仅仅一年后，当第二次世界大战爆发时，芬兰没有多余的布料来制作婴儿盒。所以设计师们必须发挥创造力。
During the moment of the war years in the 1940s, because of restrictions on materials and because of thrift, some of the clothes were paper rather than, fabric. Clean paper clothes were still better than old rags, and a simple sheet of paper could make a big difference during childbirth. In some of the very early baby boxes, there was also the sheet of paper to give birth on, to be able to create an immediate sterile birthing environment in a very low cost, but very effective manner. When the war ended, Finnish mothers could thankfully put aside their paper baby clothes. Post-war boxes included fabric and yarn, so moms could simply
在20世纪40年代的战争岁月里，由于材料限制和节俭，一些衣服是纸做的，而不是布做的。干净的纸衣服仍然比旧破布好，一张简单的纸在分娩时也能发挥很大作用。在一些非常早期的婴儿盒里，还有一张用来分娩的纸，以便以非常低成本但非常有效的方式创造一个即时的无菌分娩环境。战争结束后，芬兰母亲们谢天谢地可以把纸质婴儿服收起来了。战后的盒子里包括了布料和纱线，这样妈妈们就可以……
use all their free time to sew or knit the clothes themselves. Around this time, Finland also made a change that would become a key feature of the baby box. In 1949, they made the box a universal benefit. It was initially given out to people who needed it, and very quickly from the 1940s became given to anybody, everybody. It became a citizen's right in Finland. Most of us are probably familiar with the Nordic countries and their universal. welfare programs. Denmark, Sweden, Norway, Iceland and Finland all provide stronger social support than most other countries in the world. And in Finland, the baby box was one of the first building
利用所有的空闲时间自己缝制或编织衣服。大约在这个时候，芬兰还做了一项改变，后来成为婴儿盒的一个关键特征。1949年，他们将婴儿盒变成了一项全民福利。它最初是发给有需要的人，但从20世纪40年代开始，很快就变成了发给任何人，每个人。它成为了芬兰公民的一项权利。我们大多数人可能都熟悉北欧国家及其全民福利计划。丹麦、瑞典、挪威、冰岛和芬兰提供的社会支持都比世界上大多数其他国家要强。在芬兰，婴儿盒是建立该体系的第一块……
blocks in creating that system. The Finnish welfare state as we know it began in the aftermath of World War II. Finland, like the rest of Europe, was still recovering from the devastation of war. People had come back from the brink of the end of the world, and across the continent, they asking themselves, what do we want? What do we value now that we have a chance to make a new world? In Finland, one of the strongest new convictions was that families, all families, should have support. Some of the earliest universal policies were focused on child rearing, free school meals, quarterly child payments, and new maternal health clinics opening all over the country. The baby box was actually one way to incentivize pregnant women to use those new health clinics.
基石之一。我们所知的芬兰福利国家始于二战之后。芬兰和欧洲其他国家一样，仍在从战争的破坏中恢复。人们从世界末日的边缘归来，在整个欧洲大陆，他们都在问自己：我们想要什么？既然我们有机会创造一个新世界，我们重视什么？在芬兰，最坚定的新信念之一是家庭，所有家庭，都应该得到支持。最早的一些全民政策集中在育儿、免费学校午餐、季度儿童津贴，以及在全国各地开设新的孕产妇健康诊所。婴儿盒实际上是激励孕妇使用这些新健康诊所的一种方式。
In order to get the box, they would have to attend the maternity and welfare clinics and to get their health checked when they were expecting a baby. The lure of the baby box seems to have worked. By the early 1950s, more than 90% of mothers had registered themselves at the new clinics. Almost 80 years later, the deal is basically the same. If you visit a prenatal clinic in the first four months of pregnancy, you get the box. What's inside the box, though, changes every year. Should we start with the oldest box?
为了得到盒子，她们必须参加孕产妇和福利诊所，并在怀孕时进行健康检查。婴儿盒的诱惑似乎奏效了。到20世纪50年代初，超过90%的母亲在新的诊所注册。近80年后，这笔交易基本没变。如果你在怀孕的前四个月去产前诊所检查，你就能得到盒子。不过，盒子里的东西每年都在变。我们要从最旧的盒子开始看吗？
I visited the office of Keller, the government agency responsible for the box. They've got 40 years' worth of boxes stored away in their warehouse. So this is from 1994. So more than 30 years old. This is the snow seat. It's very 90s. Yeah, the patterns. Patterns and fabrics.
我参观了负责婴儿盒的政府机构凯拉的办公室。他们的仓库里储存了40年的盒子。这是1994年的。所以有30多年了。这是雪地服。非常有90年代风格。是的，图案。图案和面料。
Lime green stripes and fluorescent yellow. Yeah, it's very 90s. Today, Anina and her colleague Vera are responsible for deciding what each year's baby box will include. And it's a lot of pressure. Every item they pick out, be it a koala sleeping bag or a dinosaur toothbrush, will be used by thousands of families in thousands of homes all across Finland. The process of making those decisions actually begins two years before the box is set to release when they meet with a group of advisors. The group is essentially a justice list. of baby stuff experts.
酸橙绿条纹和荧光黄。是的，非常有90年代的感觉。今天，安妮娜和她的同事维拉负责决定每年婴儿盒里包含什么。压力很大。她们挑选的每一件物品，无论是考拉睡袋还是恐龙牙刷，都将被芬兰成千上万个家庭在成千上万个家里使用。做出这些决定的过程实际上在盒子发布前两年就开始了，那时她们会与一组顾问会面。这组人本质上是一个……
There's a representative from the maternity and child welfare clinics, another from the Finnish Institute for Health and Welfare, one from the Ministry of Social Affairs and Health, which sounds like the same words just rearranged. And also from the Finnish safety and chemical agency,
婴儿用品专家名单。有一位来自孕产妇和儿童福利诊所的代表，一位来自芬兰健康与福利研究所的代表，一位来自社会事务与卫生部的代表（听起来像是同样的词重新排列组合），还有来自芬兰安全与化学品管理局的代表，
there's this person who we can consult about the safety issues for the items in the package. So we have these discussions about the items, which to include or what are we planning to choose. When it comes to making the final call
有这样一个人，我们可以就礼包中物品的安全问题进行咨询。所以我们会讨论这些物品，包括哪些，或者我们计划选择什么。当谈到最终决定……
about what's in each year's box, Finnish law says that all items need to, quote, provide for the health and well-being of mother and child. And most of the time, the connection between item and well-being is obvious. It would be hard to make an argument against putting in a bath thermometer, say, or a teething toy. But other times, the connection is less about need
关于每年盒子里装什么时，芬兰法律规定所有物品都需要“为母亲和孩子的健康与福祉提供保障”。大多数时候，物品与福祉之间的联系是显而易见的。很难反对放入一个洗澡温度计或一个磨牙玩具。但有时，这种联系与其说是关于需求，
and more about encouraging certain behaviours. The box has always been about subtly influencing people's decisions. Remember, when the baby box first became a universal benefit, it was because the Finnish government wanted mothers to start going to health clinics for prenatal exams. And so despite the box's popularity, it's always carried a degree of tension between the preferences of individuals and the goals of the state. Here's Michelle Miller Fisher again. The baby box, for me, is this shining example of,
不如说是关于鼓励某些行为。婴儿盒一直以来都是为了微妙地影响人们的决定。记住，当婴儿盒首次成为全民福利时，是因为芬兰政府希望母亲们开始去健康诊所进行产前检查。因此，尽管婴儿盒很受欢迎，但它在个人偏好和国家目标之间始终存在一定程度的张力。这是米歇尔·米勒·费舍尔再次发言。对我来说，婴儿盒是……
a welfare state done right, and yet, almost every object that is designed for the arc of human reproduction is fraught with politics. Take, for example, one item you won't find in your box, a baby bottle. That's because Finland strongly recommends breastfeeding for the first four to six months. A bottle, in that case, would be unnecessary. Another item where you can see the Finnish government trying to shape behavior is the condoms they included in the 1970s. That's when the Finnish government basically said, we think family planning is part of a healthy life for everyone. Here's a way you can make a decision about whether or not you want to get pregnant again right now.
福利国家做得好的光辉典范，然而，几乎每一件为人类生殖周期设计的物品都充满了政治色彩。以你的盒子里找不到的一件物品为例：奶瓶。这是因为芬兰强烈建议前四到六个月进行母乳喂养。在这种情况下，奶瓶是不必要的。另一件你可以看到芬兰政府试图塑造行为的物品是他们在20世纪70年代放入的避孕套。那时芬兰政府基本上说：我们认为计划生育是每个人健康生活的一部分。这是一种你可以决定是否现在想再次怀孕的方法。
Not everyone appreciated the hint. Here's Tanya Vaticari, Professor of History at Tampa University. Many saw or understood that this would be a good idea. Those who were against thought that the state should not be interfering in those. kinds of ways into the family's lives. It's an issue that also came up with nappies or diapers. Early boxes included pieces of fabric that could be folded into diapers. But when the disposable kind got popular in the 1960s,
并非每个人都领情。这是坦佩雷大学历史学教授坦尼娅·瓦蒂卡里。许多人看到或理解这会是一个好主意。那些反对的人认为，国家不应该以那种方式干涉家庭生活。这个问题也出现在尿布或纸尿裤上。早期的盒子里包括可以折叠成尿布的布料。但当一次性尿布在20世纪60年代流行起来时，
those went into the baby box instead. That is until 2006, when experts decided it would be better for the environment to switch back to cloth diapers. And people were very strongly either for or against. Many people thought that these reusable diapers being in the box was the kind of a ideological message on part of the state that people should be using these types of nappies more, which was of course true. That was the idea. So was there a sense of resentment at all or if people were feeling they were being nudged too much? Yes, there was. There was exactly. that that they were pushed towards something they did not want to adopt.
那些东西就进了婴儿盒。直到2006年，专家们认为改回布尿布对环境更好。人们对此非常强烈地支持或反对。许多人认为这些可重复使用的尿布出现在盒子里是国家的一种意识形态信息，即人们应该更多地使用这类尿布，这当然是真的。这就是初衷。那么，人们是否感到不满，或者觉得被推得太过了？是的，确实。确实有那种感觉，他们被推向了他们不想采用的东西。
In the end, this particular nudge didn't work. Anina said that the majority of parents reported not using the cloth diapers. So just a few years later, they were out again. The Finnish Social Security Agency Kella puts out a survey so that parents can directly voice their opinions about what's in the box. But Anina says that a lot of those discussions play out on internet forums. There's a lot of online discussions about the items in the box and they sometimes fight also about the items. A couple of years ago, a blanket wasn't included and there was an uproar.
最终，这种特殊的推动并没有奏效。安妮娜说，大多数父母报告说没有使用布尿布。所以仅仅几年后，它们又被移除了。芬兰社会保险局凯拉发布了一项调查，以便父母可以直接表达他们对盒子里物品的看法。但安妮娜说，很多讨论是在互联网论坛上进行的。网上有很多关于盒子里物品的讨论，他们有时也会因为这些物品而争吵。几年前，毯子没有被包括在内，引起了轩然大波。
It had to be brought back by popular demand. So Anina and her colleagues have found little ways to let parents feel like they have more of a say. Yeah, actually we have had since 2020, we have had this opportunity for our clients to vote, which patents to choose for the overall and for the sleeping bags. And do people, do a lot of people vote? I think last time it was like 10,000 or something like that, so quite many.
由于大众的需求，它不得不被加回来。所以安妮娜和她的同事们找到了一些小方法，让父母觉得他们有更多的发言权。是的，实际上自2020年以来，我们让客户有机会投票选择连体衣和睡袋的图案。人们会投票吗？很多人投票吗？我想上次大概有10,000人左右，所以相当多。
Something I kept thinking about while reporting this story is that the box came about at a time when Finns were poor and infant mortality was a big problem. Now, Finland is consistently ranked among nations with the lowest infant mortality. It's also frequently named as the best country in the world, to be a parent. That's partly because of the whole comprehensive package of social support that Finland gives families.
在报道这个故事时，我一直在思考的一件事是，婴儿盒出现的时候，芬兰人很穷，婴儿死亡率是一个大问题。现在，芬兰始终被列为婴儿死亡率最低的国家之一。它也经常被评为世界上最适合做父母的国家。这部分是因为芬兰为家庭提供的全面社会支持方案。
Finnish parents have universal health care, heavily subsidized childcare, and generous parental leave. But it's also because the box did its job. So does that mean the baby box has outlived its usefulness? What would be the reaction if, do you think, if the government took away the baby books? it makes people feel a lot of feelings. So I think they would be quite angry if it would, they would stop it. It's beloved. Yes, it's beloved.
芬兰父母拥有全民医疗保健、高额补贴的托儿服务和慷慨的育儿假。但这也是因为婴儿盒完成了它的使命。那么，这是否意味着婴儿盒已经失去了它的用处？你认为如果政府取消婴儿盒，会有什么反应？这会让人们产生很多感受。所以我认为如果他们停止它，人们会非常生气。它深受喜爱。是的，它深受喜爱。
Parents actually have a choice about whether or not they take the baby box or a cash alternative. At this moment it's 210 euros, cash, or the box. But most people choose the box. Almost all first-time mothers choose. just a box. And just like in the early days, many still use that simple cardboard box as a crib. Almost half of finished babies at some point sleep in the box.
父母实际上可以选择要婴儿盒还是现金替代品。目前是210欧元现金或盒子。但大多数人选择盒子。几乎所有初为人母的母亲都选择……只是盒子。就像早期一样，许多人仍然把那个简单的纸箱当作婴儿床。几乎一半的芬兰婴儿在某个阶段睡在盒子里。
Collecting and unpacking the box has become a rite of passage in Finland. Future grandparents and even great-grandparents might come over to pour over the contents and reminisce over what they received in their boxes. It's very common to find old baby boxes in finished garages and attics, filled with favourite items from the box waiting to be taken out for the next generation. Another reason the baby box remains a constant and finished life is the way it lifts the mental load of being a new parent. The box is simple and curated,
收集和拆开盒子已经成为芬兰的一种成人礼。未来的祖父母甚至曾祖父母可能会过来翻看里面的东西，回忆他们当年收到的盒子。在芬兰的车库和阁楼里找到旧的婴儿盒是很常见的，里面装满了从盒子里拿出来的最爱物品，等待着下一代使用。婴儿盒在芬兰生活中保持不变的另一个原因是它减轻了新手父母的心理负担。盒子简单且经过精心挑选，
telling you exactly what you need in order to care for a baby and what you don't. Having a newborn is tough. Any parent will remember feeling disorientated, anxious, and desperate for sleep, all of which makes you the perfect target for advertisers hawking miracle products. If you don't have this, your baby won't be safe, or they won't be healthy, or they won't be smart, etc.
准确地告诉你照顾婴儿需要什么，不需要什么。养育新生儿很艰难。任何父母都会记得那种迷失方向、焦虑和渴望睡眠的感觉，所有这些都使你成为兜售奇迹产品的广告商的完美目标。如果你没有这个，你的宝宝就不会安全，或者他们就不会健康，或者他们就不会聪明，等等。
I mean, obviously, we live in a capitalist society. This is the way in which parents are turned into a demographic or a space of marketing and consumption. I've seen ads for an intravaginal speaker to encourage language development while still in the womb. And pillows shaped like giant hands, so your baby feels like they're being. being held as they sleep.
我的意思是，显然，我们生活在一个资本主义社会。这就是父母被转化为人口统计学或营销和消费空间的方式。我见过一种阴道内扬声器的广告，说是为了在胎儿还在子宫里时鼓励语言发展。还有形状像巨大手的枕头，这样你的宝宝在睡觉时会感觉自己被……被抱着。
It's so easy to laugh at these products when you're not in the depths of life with a newborn. But at the time, I'd have paid a lot of money for something that guaranteed me a tiny bit more sleep or the chance to go to the bathroom on my own or five minutes to drink a hot cup of coffee. In the haze of those early days, it's so hard to tell what you actually need.
当你不在养育新生儿的深渊中时，很容易嘲笑这些产品。但在当时，我会花很多钱买任何能保证我多睡一会儿，或者有机会独自去洗手间，或者有五分钟时间喝杯热咖啡的东西。在那些早期的迷雾中，很难分辨你真正需要什么。
I spoke about this with a Finnish mother named Mary. When she was pregnant, a friend not from Finland had helpfully sent her a spreadsheet with everything that'd suggest a new parent buys. And it was so long of all the possible things that you could need. From clothes to what kind of bathtub to little silver nipple cups that you can wear so that when you're breastfeeding you're to help with the pain of that. And I was glad that I don't really have to think about that. I could know that all the main things were already thought of.
我和一位名叫玛丽的芬兰母亲谈过这件事。当她怀孕时，一位非芬兰的朋友好心地给她发了一份电子表格，上面有建议新手父母购买的所有东西。清单非常长，列出了所有你可能需要的东西。从衣服到什么样的浴盆，再到你可以戴的小银色乳头罩，这样你在母乳喂养时可以帮助缓解疼痛。我很高兴我真的不需要考虑这些。我知道所有主要的事情都已经考虑到了。
And I guess there's the message as well if your baby's sleeping in a box that, you know, that's fine. You know, you don't need fancy things. Like, these are the basics that you really need. But even more important than the practical benefit to parents is what the baby box stands for. 80 plus years after it helped build the foundation of the Finnish welfare system, the box is still inseparable from the culture it helped create.
我想这也传达了一个信息：如果你的宝宝睡在盒子里，你知道，那没关系。你知道，你不需要昂贵的东西。这些就是你真正需要的基本用品。但比对父母的实际好处更重要的是婴儿盒所代表的意义。在它帮助建立芬兰福利体系基础80多年后，这个盒子仍然与它所帮助创造的文化密不可分。
The kind of idea that everyone gets the same start to life, I think, is important for finish people. The baby box creates a sort of visual equality. There's no stigma in using the items from the box because everybody does. Really? It can actually be a problem picking out which child is yours when they're all running around in their identical snowsuits. And you kind of know that they're probably around the same age as your baby because
每个人都有相同的生命起点的想法，我认为对芬兰人来说很重要。婴儿盒创造了一种视觉上的平等。使用盒子里物品没有任何耻辱感，因为每个人都用。真的吗？当他们都穿着一模一样的雪地服跑来跑去时，挑选哪个孩子是你的实际上可能是一个问题。而且你隐约知道他们可能和你宝宝的年龄差不多，因为……
they're wearing the same stuff. There's something about, definitely something about the shared experience. that you know everyone in Finland will have gone through of getting this box and using the same things and knowing that everyone's getting kind of quality items. There are really few more powerful equalizers than having everyone start life sleeping in an identical cardboard box. And I can't help but feel a little awe that this program that started so many years ago has persisted all this time.
他们穿着同样的东西。这确实与共享体验有关，你知道芬兰的每个人都会经历过收到这个盒子、使用同样的东西，并且知道每个人得到的都是某种高质量的物品。没有什么比让每个人都睡在同一个纸箱里开始生活更能体现平等了。我不禁感到一丝敬畏，这个多年前开始的项目竟然坚持了这么久。
The current right-wing government is making deep cuts to everything from housing support, unemployment benefits, health care, and child benefits. But no one from any political party is seriously talking about getting rid of the box. It is just too much of an icon. There's something incredibly beautiful about looking at a society, looking at this promise that a government makes to its people, that it takes from its taxes, so it's a people making this promise to themselves as well, that we will provide for the newest, the most vulnerable, the tiniest,
当前的右翼政府正在对从住房补贴、失业救济金、医疗保健到儿童福利的一切进行大幅削减。但没有任何政党的人在认真讨论取消这个盒子。它太具标志性了。看着一个社会，看着政府对其人民做出的这个承诺，即它从税收中提取资金（所以这也是人民对自己做出的承诺），即我们将为社会中最年轻、最脆弱、最微小、
the most promising people in our society because it's paying it forward, but it's also paying it back to ourselves. It's infesting in this larger, yeah, social compact or social agreement that we have with one another. The concept of baby boxes is now spread across the world. There are versions of the box in Chile, South Africa, Canada, and Scotland. Michelle actually received a Scottish box. It's full of what one of her mentors called humble masterpieces. Everyday objects. that seem unremarkable, but are nonetheless worthy of celebration. I love the sling that is in there. So there's just a long, it's not a constructed sling,
最充满希望的人提供保障，这本身就非常美丽，因为它是在传递爱心，但也是在回馈我们自己。它是在投资于我们彼此之间更大的社会契约或社会协议。婴儿盒的概念现在已经传播到世界各地。智利、南非、加拿大和苏格兰都有这种盒子的版本。米歇尔实际上收到过一个苏格兰盒子。它装满了她的一位导师所说的“谦逊的杰作”。日常物品，
it's just a long piece of fabric. Several yards of very stretchy, grey, heather grey fabric. In one of Michelle's earliest pictures of her daughter March, she's just a few days old and she's being carried in that sling by her dad, Austin. It took us, we did seven rounds of IVF to have our daughter, and it was the only pregnancy that actually worked. And so we waited years to have her. And this picture that I have of Austin, he just, he looks so happy.
看起来平淡无奇，但却值得赞美。我喜欢里面的背带。所以它只是一个很长的，它不是一个结构化的背带，
It's making me feel emotional even now because it's just so special. This is the paradox of the baby box. It's full of practical items, boring items even. But that box and all its mundane contents connect you to the most profound moments of your life. And in Finland, to generations of parents. parents before you, all of them tucking their newborn children into the humble masterpiece of a simple cardboard box. After the break, Olivia Humphreys takes us on a tour of baby boxes around the world. We're back with Olivia Humphreys. Hey, Livya.
它只是一块长布。几码非常弹性的、灰色的、石楠灰色的布料。在米歇尔最早的一张女儿马奇的照片中，她才几天大，正被她的爸爸奥斯汀用那条背带背着。我们做了七轮试管婴儿才有了我们的女儿，这是唯一一次真正成功的怀孕。所以我们等了多年才有了她。而我这张奥斯汀的照片，他看起来太幸福了。
Hey, Roman. How you doing? I'm good, I'm good. So at the end of the story, you mentioned that there are baby box projects in other parts of the world, too. Yeah, so for decades, the finished baby box was really the only game in town. But in the last 20 years or so, that's changed. I spoke to Dr. Anorina Kuyivu, who's a researcher at Tampa University in Finland, and she did the first global study that maps baby box projects around the world. She said she and her co-authors were kind of amazed at how far and wide that idea of the baby box had spread. We were really surprised, and it was also a lovely surprise. We found over 90 projects all around the world in about 60 countries, places like Papua New Guinea. There were several in Africa, Latin America, and also Southeast Asia, and so on.
即使现在也让我感到情绪激动，因为它太特别了。这就是婴儿盒的悖论。它装满了实用的物品，甚至是无聊的物品。但那个盒子及其所有平凡的内容将你与生命中最深刻的时刻联系在一起。在芬兰，它连接着你之前的几代父母，他们都把新生儿塞进那个简单的纸箱这一“谦逊的杰作”里。休息之后，奥利维亚·汉弗莱斯将带我们参观世界各地的婴儿盒。我们和奥利维亚·汉弗莱斯回来了。嘿，利维亚。
So there have now been baby box schemes on every continent except Antarctica. That's slacken. But are all these baby boxes like universal programs like the Finnish one? Actually, there's only two other countries where all pregnant women in the nation are eligible to get a box. and that's Chile and Scotland. Some of the other projects are for pregnant women in a particular geographical area, in a state or in a city, for instance. And then others are even more targeted
嘿，罗曼。你好吗？我很好，我很好。所以在故事的最后，你提到世界其他地方也有婴儿盒项目。是的，几十年来，芬兰婴儿盒确实是唯一的选择。但在过去20年左右，情况发生了变化。我采访了芬兰坦佩雷大学的研究员阿诺丽娜·库伊武博士，她做了第一个绘制世界各地婴儿盒项目的全球研究。她说她和她的合著者对婴儿盒这个想法传播得如此之广感到惊讶。我们真的很惊讶，这也是一个可爱的惊喜。我们在大约60个国家发现了全球100多个项目，比如巴布亚新几内亚。非洲、拉丁美洲和东南亚等地也有几个，等等。
to the people who need it. Very specific, vulnerable groups like first-time moms. Sometimes these are low-income moms. Women in jail, refugee moms, or HIV-positive moms. And this is more like the original Finnish baby boxes.
所以现在除了南极洲，每个大洲都有婴儿盒计划。那是懒惰。但所有这些婴儿盒都是像芬兰那样的全民项目吗？实际上，只有另外两个国家的所有孕妇都有资格获得盒子，那就是智利和苏格兰。其他一些项目是针对特定地理区域、州或城市的孕妇。还有一些则更具针对性，
Like, this is support going for the people who need the most support. Right. But unlike in Finland, most of these programs aren't actually run by the state. Some of them are, but the vast majority are run by research groups or hospitals, NGOs, non-profits or private parties, or by United Nations agencies like UNICEF. And how similar are the boxes themselves to the Finnish ones? Obviously, these boxes are being used in totally. different contexts and so they have been adapted a lot, which is kind of the beauty of the
针对那些需要它的人。非常具体、脆弱的群体，比如初为人母的母亲。有时是低收入母亲。监狱里的妇女、难民母亲或艾滋病毒阳性母亲。这更像最初的芬兰婴儿盒。
baby box, I think, is such a flexible idea. In fact, one of the things that Anarina learned is that in some places the box isn't even a box. We talk about baby box because it's a sort of a common name that is often used, but not all baby boxes are boxes and not all baby boxes should be boxes either because it's very important that the baby box is appropriate for that context. So one of those instances where a cardboard box just didn't make sense was in South Africa. The box there was designed for mothers in a poor settlement and a cardboard box was just not robust enough to work in that context where there are insects and rats and it's very humid. So they decided that it makes more sense to put the items in a bag.
就像这样，支持是给那些最需要支持的人的。对。但与芬兰不同的是，这些项目大多数实际上不是由国家运营的。有些是，但绝大多数是由研究小组或医院、非政府组织、非营利组织或私人团体，或者像联合国儿童基金会这样的联合国机构运营的。那么盒子本身和芬兰的有多相似？显然，这些盒子是在完全不同的背景下使用的，所以它们被大量改编，我认为这就是婴儿盒的美妙之处，
bathtub and that bathtub was used then for washing the baby. A plastic baby bath also made sense because in South Africa it's the norm for parents to co-sleep with babies. So the project designers thought a bathtub would get more use than a crib. And then in other places, boxes weren't used because they had negative connotations in that culture. For instance, in Malavian culture, where they first sort of considered a card box that was not supported by the mothers because it resembled a coffin. So it was not a good choice for a baby box and the program opted for a baby basket instead. That makes a complete sense. So you have baskets, you have bathtubs. What else do you have? So even if they didn't go with the box, a lot of the
它是一个如此灵活的想法。事实上，阿诺丽娜学到的一件事是，在某些地方，盒子甚至不是一个盒子。我们谈论婴儿盒是因为它是一种常用的名称，但并非所有的婴儿盒都是盒子，也不应该都是盒子，因为婴儿盒适合该背景非常重要。所以纸箱根本行不通的例子之一是在南非。那里的盒子是为贫民窟的母亲设计的，纸箱在那种有昆虫、老鼠且非常潮湿的环境中不够坚固。所以他们决定把物品放在一个盆里更有意义，
projects borrowed that idea from Finland of the container having its own use. So there have been buckets for washing clothes in, bags that can double up as a kind of sling, bamboo rocking cradles in India. And in terms of what's inside the box or the basket or the bucket, like presumably that changes a lot, too, depending on the environment. I mean, some of it is the same. There's usually some basic hygiene items like soap, lots of clothes, obviously appropriate for the climate. You don't get many insulated mittens in sub-Saharan Africa like you do in Finland. But if it's an area where, say, malaria or Zika are prevalent, then boxes might include a mosquito net.
那个盆后来被用来给宝宝洗澡。塑料婴儿浴盆也很有意义，因为在南非，父母与婴儿同睡是常态。所以项目设计师认为浴盆比婴儿床更有用。而在其他地方，盒子没有被使用，因为它们在那种文化中有负面含义。例如，在马拉维文化中，他们最初考虑过纸箱，但没有得到母亲们的支持，因为它像棺材。所以它不是婴儿盒的好选择，该项目选择了婴儿篮。这完全说得通。所以你有篮子，有浴盆。还有什么？所以即使他们没有选择盒子，很多项目也借鉴了芬兰关于容器本身有用途的想法。所以有用来洗衣服的桶、可以兼作背带的袋子、印度的竹制摇篮。至于盒子、篮子或桶里装什么，大概也会根据环境发生很大变化。我的意思是，有些是一样的。通常会有一些基本的卫生用品，比如肥皂，当然还有很多适合气候的衣服。你在撒哈拉以南非洲不会像在芬兰那样得到很多绝缘连指手套。但如果是在疟疾或寨卡病毒流行的地方，那么盒子里可能会包括蚊帐。
Or if the mother can't access a hospital very easily, then there might be items to make delivery at home safer, like a sterile razor blades to cut the umbilical cord or a plastic sheet to give birth on. I mean, this is kind of the equivalent of the paper sheet from the early finished baby boxes. Exactly, yes. Yeah, yeah.
或者如果母亲不容易去医院，那么可能会有一些让在家分娩更安全的物品，比如切割脐带的无菌剃须刀片或用来分娩的塑料布。我的意思是，这相当于早期芬兰婴儿盒里的纸张。完全正确，是的。是的，是的。
And are there conditions with getting these other boxes in other countries. Like in Finland, you mentioned that, you know, they have to attend a prenatal appointment. You know, is the same for other projects? Yeah, the baby boxes almost always come with strings attached. And that's kind of the point of a lot of these programs. They're trying to get babies into their healthcare system. So in Zambia, for instance, you can't get the box unless you give birth at a healthcare facility. And in Mexico, you can only get the box once you've registered your baby's birth. And so which country is most like the classic Finnish? Baby box? Probably Scotland. The scheme's been going there for about a decade and it's been
在其他国家获得这些盒子有条件吗？就像在芬兰，你提到他们必须参加产前预约。其他项目也是这样吗？是的，婴儿盒几乎总是附带条件的。这正是许多此类项目的目的。他们试图让婴儿进入他们的医疗保健系统。例如，在赞比亚，除非你在医疗机构分娩，否则你拿不到盒子。在墨西哥，只有在登记了宝宝的出生后才能拿到盒子。那么哪个国家最像经典的芬兰婴儿盒？可能是苏格兰。该计划在那里已经实施了大约十年，自开始以来一直非常受欢迎。
really popular ever since it started. Take-up's been around 90%, so that's roughly the same as Finland. But when it was first brought in, there was some controversy, particularly around that idea of babies sleeping in cardboard boxes. Okay. What happened? Well, the right-leaning Scottish Sun newspaper tried to turn public feeling against it. They actually made a video. which they've now deleted, where they set fire to the box to show that it was flammable. They wanted to demonstrate on YouTube that a cardboard box was flammable. Yeah, and actually because the box is made from this kind of heavy-duty corrugated cardboard, it actually took seven minutes of concerted efforts with a lighter to set it on fire.
采用率一直在90%左右，所以和芬兰差不多。但当它刚被引入时，出现了一些争议，特别是关于婴儿睡在纸箱里的想法。好吧。发生了什么？嗯，右倾的《苏格兰太阳报》试图煽动公众情绪反对它。他们实际上制作了一个视频（现在已经删除了），他们在视频中点燃了盒子以证明它是易燃的。他们想在YouTube上演示纸箱是易燃的。是的，实际上因为盒子是由这种重型瓦楞纸板制成的，用打火机点燃它实际上需要七分钟的持续努力。
So it wasn't quite the gotcha that they were looking for. Yeah. And obviously it didn't have much effective. 90% of people are taking the boxes. Yeah, and they also weren't convinced about the boxes not being safe to sleep in. So about 40% of people use it for babies to sleep in, just like in Finland. So you mentioned that new boxes and new box programs are cropping up all the time. What's the latest place to get a baby box or have a program like this in the works? So New York Mayor Zora and Mamdani had a proposal for baby baskets for all newborns in the city as part of his campaign last year. That sounds like him.
所以这并不是他们想要的“抓包”效果。是的，显然它没有产生什么影响。90%的人都在领取盒子。是的，他们也不相信盒子不适合睡觉。所以大约40%的人用它给宝宝睡觉，就像在芬兰一样。所以你提到新的盒子和新的盒子项目一直在涌现。最近获得婴儿盒或有类似计划的地方是哪里？所以纽约市长佐拉和马姆达尼在去年的竞选活动中提议为全市所有新生儿提供婴儿篮。这听起来像他。
Yes. And Wales actually has just started a government-funded program as well. But at the moment, it's only for babies who are in the most deprived parts of the country. And the response really highlights one of the problems with these targeted projects, which is that people are saying anecdotally that they might not use the clothes that are in the box because they feel like there's a stigma attached. So it's kind of the opposite of that feeling of togetherness and belonging that people in Finland describe. And for people who are listening who really want to get their hands on a baby box,
是的。威尔士实际上也刚刚启动了一个政府资助的项目。但目前，它只针对该国最贫困地区的婴儿。而反应确实突出了这些针对性项目的问题之一，即人们传闻说他们可能不会使用盒子里面的衣服，因为他们觉得有耻辱感。所以这与芬兰人描述的那种团结和归属感恰恰相反。对于那些正在收听、非常想得到婴儿盒的人来说，
like this all sounds great, but they don't live in New York or Wales or Scotland or Chile and all these fantastic places. Do you have advice for them? So Keller, who are the government department who are responsible for giving out the box in Finland, they get emails all the time, they say, from people who would love to pay for a box. But it's illegal for Keller to sell the box because it's the state benefits. Right. It's just like it's illegal for me to listen to BBC Sounds in the United States. Right. Yeah, sorry about that. But inevitably, some canny entrepreneurs have spotted that there's a gap in the market, and they've started
这听起来都很棒，但他们不住在纽约、威尔士、苏格兰或智利以及所有这些奇妙的地方。你有什么建议给他们吗？凯拉，也就是负责在芬兰发放盒子的政府部门，他们说他们一直收到来自那些很乐意花钱买盒子的人的电子邮件。但凯拉出售盒子是非法的，因为它是国家福利。对。就像我在美国听BBC Sounds是非法的一样。对。是的，很抱歉。但不可避免地，一些精明的企业家发现了市场空白，他们已经开始……
selling commercial baby boxes. One of the first companies doing that was founded by three Finnish dance, and they just started off pretty much including what was in the keller boxes. But then they started getting feedback from customers in Australia who didn't have much use for the snow suit, and they switched it so that you'd get different stuff, depending on where in the world you are. Yeah, so it's complicated to make an internationally appropriate baby box. Yeah, yeah. So they're not exactly flying off shelves. Not really. One issue is that in the United States, back in 2021, it became illegal to sell a cardboard box marketed as a sleeping space for a baby because it was decided it just didn't meet safety guidelines. But even in other parts of the world, a lot of the businesses who sell these boxes seem to have gone bust after a few years. And obviously, I don't know why that's happened exactly. But I do wonder if the appeal of the box is really that sense of being cared for and being part of something. And that's what people want to appease of. you just don't get that feeling from a box that's been sold to you by a commercial company.
销售商业婴儿盒。最早做这件事的公司之一是由三位芬兰舞蹈家创立的，他们起初基本上就是把凯拉盒子里有的东西放进去。但后来他们开始收到澳大利亚客户的反馈，说他们不太用得上雪地服，于是他们进行了调整，根据你所在的世界不同地区提供不同的物品。是的，所以制作一个国际通用的婴儿盒很复杂。是的，没错。所以它们并不是特别畅销。确实不是。一个问题是，在美国，早在2021年，销售作为婴儿睡眠空间营销的纸板箱就变得不合法了，因为人们认为它不符合安全准则。但即使在世界其他地方，许多销售这些盒子的企业似乎也在几年后倒闭了。显然，我不知道具体原因。但我确实在想，婴儿盒的吸引力是否真的在于那种被关怀和成为某件事一部分的感觉。而这正是人们想要满足的。你从一家商业公司卖给你的盒子里根本得不到那种感觉。
It just loses a lot of the magic, and it's just kind of a cardboard box full of clothes that you didn't choose. Yeah. This is so much fun. Thank you so much for doing the story for us. It's been such a pleasure. Thank you, Roman. 99% Invisible was reported this week by Olivia Humphreys, edited by Kelly Prime, mixed by Martine
它失去了很多魔力，这只是一种装满了你没选过的衣服的纸板箱。是的。这太有趣了。非常感谢你为我们做这个报道。这真是太愉快了。谢谢你，罗曼。《99%隐形》本周由奥利维亚·汉弗莱斯报道，凯利·普莱姆编辑，马丁混音。
Martin Gonzalez, music by Swan Real and George Langford. Fact-checking by Graham Hesha. Special thanks this week to Pia of Roak. Kolsky, as well as Mary's mom, Tina. Kathy, too, is our executive producer. Kurt Kolstad is the digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Barubei, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald,
马丁·冈萨雷斯，音乐由斯旺·里尔和乔治·兰福德创作。事实核查由格雷厄姆·赫沙完成。本周特别感谢皮亚·奥夫·罗阿克·科尔斯基，以及玛丽的妈妈蒂娜。凯西·图是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监。德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、杰森·德莱昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德，
Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Lashamadon, Joe Rosenberg, Jacob Medina Gleason, Talon and Rain Stradley, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% Invisible Logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Series XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora, building in beautiful uptown Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI and 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·莱、拉沙马顿、乔·罗森伯格、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森、塔隆和雷恩·斯特拉德利，以及我，罗曼·马斯。《99%隐形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们是SiriusXM播客家族的一部分，现在总部位于加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心以北六个街区的潘多拉大厦。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站以及我们自己的Discord服务器上找到我们。那里有一个链接，以及《99PI》的所有往期节目，网址是99PI.org。本集目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。